[موسيقى]
اختلفت اليوم الاخبار عن السابق متعدده
المصادر التي نحصل منها على المعلومات في
السابق تلقى الاخبار عن طريق الصحف او
القنوات التلفزيونيه اما اليوم فاصبحت
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في الوسيله التي
نتلقى منها الاخبار بشكل اسرع واسهل هذا
بكل تاكيد اثر على مستقيه المعلومات فمتى
نشعر بان الخبر مزيف او كاذب
[موسيقى]
في الكره الخبر كاظم
ااا اذا تاكدنا من الحسابات اذا كانت
رسميه وموثوقه او من جهه رسميه والله من
البدايه احيانا يكون الخبر في التمهيد
حقها واضح انه هو صحيح غير كذا ما يكون
موجود في التلفزيون او في الصحف الرسميه
اذا كان الخبر النصر غير موثوق او ما هو
مكان تصميم دائما تجي كثيره
واغلبها من الحسابات مزيفه يعني في مصادر
موثوقه
فيه حسابات في تويتر يعني معتمده مثلا من
قبل الجهات الرسميه وكاله الانباء
السعوديه اخبار كثير ولكن
فاهم على حسب مصدر الخبر من وين
يعني
غير لما يكون من اشخاص واطراف وكلام زايد
لما بيكون مش من جهر رسميه اكيد الخبر
كاذب وهو مزيف اذا كان من جهه رسميه او من
حدا اكيد الخبر بيكون مزبوط الاخبار جايه
ما هي من القنوات الرسميه مواقع التلفزيون
شيء رسمي فهو خبر غير
[موسيقى]